bonsoir à thème un f6 merci d'être avec
nous quand on entend la colère de ces
tunisiens la colère voilà les plus
jeunes des moins jeunes on se dit tout
ça pour ça disent ans après que
reste-t-il
et bien ce qu'il reste c'est comme ça a
été soulignée la liberté d'expression et
ce n'est pas un vain mot
cette semaine par exemple une télévision
va proposer à des jeunes de débattre de
si la révolution prend à le bon chemin
au lourd et chemin
c'est quelque chose qui est juste
inenvisageable dans les autres pays qui
ont connu une première vague des
printemps arabes
donc ça c'est très important en revanche
il ya une instabilité politique qui a
fait qu' il n'était pas possible
d'apporter les solutions à un
gouvernement dur en moyenne un an
on ne peut pas changer le modèle de
développement ne peut pas mettre une
politique économique et sociale en moins
d'un an
si on est obligé de d'effacer de
recommencer à chaque fois et donc
forcément là on a un petit recul on
s'arrête en fait un point d'étape
on se dit qu'effectivement en dix ans la
situation économique et sociale à au
moins stagné si ce n'est empiré et il
n'y a rien eu de
fondamental dans le changement du modèle
social il ya toujours les mêmes
disparités entre les régions au sein
même des régions entre les centres des
métropoles et la ceinture populaire ça
n'a pas changé les gens s'impatientent
ça fait dix ans qu'il avait une équipe
particulièrement dur mais justement
c'est terrible ce constat parce que
c'est vrai que voilà tout le monde
s'émerveille et beaucoup de volants de
médias occidentaux je disais voilà
c'était formidable cette révolution et
quel est le message et ça dit quoi
parce qu on les entendait bien là c'est
pire aujourd'hui
qu est ce qu on en retient pour quelles
raisons alors justement l'aller les
tunisiens se cherche et d'ailleurs le
cto l'enseignement du secourisme des
deux scrutins qui a eu en 2019
c'est à dire que autant ils ont
reconduit les mêmes personnes aux
législatives et donc les mêmes
les mêmes causes produisant les mêmes
conséquences on a reproduit les mêmes
donc forcément les mêmes tiraillements
politiques les mêmes les mêmes batailles
d'ego et les mêmes faux problème qui
empêche de d'attaquer les problématiques
économiques et sociales autant ils ont
tenté aussi laventure pas et c'est sarah
ide en se disant on va prendre quelqu'un
qui est totalement hors du entre
guillemets du système politique
et force est de constater qu'un an après
un essai sarrail et s'il reste très
populaire n'a pas fait grand-chose
contenu déjà de ses faibles prérogatives
mais même dans ses prérogatives il s'est
cantonné à des discours mais sans acte
aujourd'hui n'a pas pu se rendre à sidi
bouzid c'est terrible il a promis aux
gens de sidi bouzid de venir et il n'est
pas venu donc hisse donc là il se
cherche
aujourd'hui les sondages d'opinion pour
les législatives continua pour la
présidentielle continuent à plébisciter
pareils mais pour les législatives en
plébiscite là
si vous voulez l'icône de l'ancien
régime arabi et le moci qui se présente
comme une digne héritière de du système
qui a été déchu et qui propose de
refermer cette cette parenthèse de la
révolution sans alors que l'oubli de
dire que les gens se sont révoltés aussi
contre ce système donc aujourd'hui il ya
une nostalgie d'une vie moins chère de
moins d'insécurité mais en même temps si
les gens sont révoltés il ya dix ans et
que ça allait mal aussi
donc on est un petit peu dans l'impasse
et et voilà donc il ya beaucoup de
mouvements sociaux qui s'y qui secoue le
pays et qui font que voilà on se cherche
on essaye de trouver une solution mais
il me semble difficile que les gens
veuillent par contre renoncé aux
libertés qui ont obtenu puisque
aujourd'hui peuvent exprimer leur
mécontentement dans la rue donc qui a
effectivement il demande d'ordre mais en
même temps on veut pas renoncer à cette
liberté
merci merci à thème nafti essayiste
auteur de tunisie dessine-moi une
révolution merci à vous